how's it goin breasts my name and the
last episode fashio decided to suicides
he didn't quite make it by way in this
[ __ ] mess and we have to climb I
guess I have to do this in I remember in
a frigging monsters we do a good ending
I haven't uploaded that but whatever I'm
just putting it out there you probably
don't know what I'm talking about you so
yeah you're gonna yeah I have to
practice I rang a tank skills I guess
all this shit's not gonna be easy
crawl crawl faster place place I need to
go over there don't you dare fall down
I'll kick your cookie what ah this is
kinda yes yes oh wait I got it I got it
I got it oh wait I don't get it
all right baby girl
all right sweet baby go go see your
South flower color shoots are talking
you Crowley's love makes no sense
come on me a Sun Oven how the hell am I
supposed to do that I'm not cheating
it's not cheating if you think about
Lady gaga
okay so how do we do this let's think
before we do something let's get out
there no I hit my head you bet that
Jackie why can't I go forward here oh
well oh I can't go out there with that
oh no oh oh no [ __ ] I don't do it but I
don't do it whatever you know why I
don't do anything stupid right now
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] everyone take a selfie
l see L pale front oh no I don't know
she'll fails pack me no no this is
opposite of she'll pills
this is Nick all right we're here we're
here what Punjab find out whatever you
do don't do it I love you Raja there's a
life worth living
that's a tram I know it's a shitty thing
to me but you could be a best buy it
could be worse
that's at first I find you don't do it
better
I need to get up here son of a [ __ ] huh
shot son of a [ __ ] all right think
think fast think not slow come on I need
you helper here FISA Baran come on
now for this non-smokers snoop yes
penetrate
possible hi yes whoa how do I get over
there Pasha
[Music]
oh gosh I you're a fee word that was not
even funny I swear to God that took me
20 minutes to get up those that yeah at
least I have my drugs now you don't deny
my drugs
oh okay that's alright no no no don't
take the drugs no no come I don't even
care anymore it's good hey buds I love
what it's like this singing oh a Volvo
no it's an Audi god dammit I punch you
I'm sure you're not even nearly as good
as police bill alright oh nice lovely
I should probably grab one of those no
way oh-ho
get in get in oh we're gonna have some
Gideon I'm nice up in this [ __ ]
yeah yeah hey Lantern hello penny
what awesome
we're going like Stone Age on this
[ __ ]
bring it I have a Gideon Dan okay so
posh ah don't deny me why the hell am I
supposed to go perhaps in the forest ah
this reminds me of the forest parting oh
no oh no is this a Blair Witch Project
situations I hate that movie allow any
witches in this wood
I just walk in circles I think so yes I
trees bring me all that you got you see
I'm not afraid have a Gideon whoa
beautiful city I don't why I would go
today yeah but that deck stopped being a
copy-cat right I think we need to find
our way back
it's backwards ah stuff hey it's an ink
month a minute I know actually a real
name all right so don't deny me forest
don't deny me I know you love me Wow
stop denying me why do you do that why
am I supposed to push some box I can
climb over oh there's a door all right
I didn't see that door all right Gideon
I think we're in some deep [ __ ] here but
let's see what's happening all right
another Lantern hello lantern how are
you that's what you get you share okay
so I don't think we need another one of
them I think it's just to gather light
at the forest all right another one of
you hello I use checkpoint who place
your hair I need a status report or
something Gideon does not talk to me
anymore
I think Gideon is upset because I made
out with his girlfriend what I would
never do that
okay wait I followed the lantern it's
somebody here with where's the other one
it can't be that long because I came
from there or could it be an MFA I don't
know where to go green and I'm scared so
dark and creepy yeah this is the problem
whoa there's the other ones all right
there we go nothing creepy about forests
sad water no I'm not I make him zombies
but I'm not going in the water that's
his disgusting his wet that's what she
said hey I think we have to there's like
a thing to climb over there I've got
damnit
flashy flash [ __ ] jump up here
hello lantern how are you today
don't care talk to someone who cares I'm
not cheating it that's clickety-click
her too all right if you can move
normally I would be great gotcha all
right there we go
and then we will walk the teen
trendin okay don't fall down all right
well open all right here we go another
one of you huh what are y'all doing here
this is creeping me out
another does a lot of sweets today I
don't know why
all right keep going into forest I
suppose
which are you doing here Lantern yeah
y'all doing here I see another one over
here do I
whoa I see something over there
could it be oh it's the city well what
do you know
I'm so stupid they get Stockholm so many
people lit up places it makes no sense
alright keep going in the forest I
suppose a lot of [ __ ] going on in the
forest
what okay I just walk in circles
midnight [ __ ] me it's kind of hard to
orient I'm just saying supposed to walk
here trace I don't they talked it would
be my friend right now and be like
alright I'm officially lost now hope
you're happy
oh wait here it it no it isn't I was
insane but it's the other one come here
maybe man by John I don't all right I
think we got something here
yes we got something here I'm walking
backwards tonight aren't I
yes I am one [ __ ] yes
okay that's okay that's okay that's okay
they actually I'll Atlanta save here
because I don't really know probably at
the war or something I ain't see well
it's probably this direction I think
about that it is there's the door hey
lack of boughs oh let's bellevigne drive
it I will try my trailer charlie alright
let's just do a couple more minutes
whoa no no
[Music]
what is he doing here get him again
please please please don't run away from
me again I need you right now I don't
like this okay
just deep breath rainbows get honest
with you don't worry
get in this with you we got this [ __ ]
game right can you tickle my dad and fit
that Wow yeah same okay what is this
they say this is okay okay okay it does
not like that I took it
alright I'm right over here I'm out of
here I'm out of here I'm so frewcandy
frew ker I hate them I hate em there
whenever chainsaw okay one more one more
get in get gang gang gang gang gang gang
hey hey hey what are you going
not even Boeing are you going for picnic
this is not the time for a picnic
alright alright let's take the your
girls pink and then stop going sideways
I don't know what you're doing right now
all right we got this Nemus probably a
snare mask from the US okay whoa whoa
whoa whoa I think we chase oh I can't do
this I thought it was gone and then he's
there uh
hanging the chainsaw guy who's the worst
definitely definitely okay I really have
to pee I think if I continue playing a
brother gonna pee somewhere all right
like favorite read sky cover don't give
that back
no no no don't touch mess back oh no I'm
gonna kill that fast no it's not demon
BestBuy what do i do positive da da da
da da Jam I swear to God but him what
Allison down good